of the 20th of May two o'clock and as
I'm sure you know we are live on the
council YouTube channel I just would
like to say I think you know I do have
notes but a month or three weeks ago we
had our first live planning various
comments did come back from various
sources to say that they were quite
impressed of all that took part in the
way it was conducted and that's not to
do with me far from it ourselves as well
but I would just like to convey that to
you so thank you for that it's nice to
get some positive comeback I know we
don't always get that that's the role we
play okay so get on this the agenda as
similar to what we had last time if I
may I would like to ask all those in
attendance and I said this before I know
but I've got a list here they're not in
any of the bed hoarder so just because
Steve all been these other top that but
that don't mean two things to use a no
councillor Albin just say you're here
please huger councillor curry present
chair Thank You councillor Duckworth
here chair thank you I believe councils
Taylor maybe a little bit late and this
is arrived councillors esky who's
standing in for councillor Dennis here
two counts at your Beaufort nature
counts a common cook here chair
councillor heart here Jay counts the
right here chair councillor Ghana I'm
here Thank You councillor Scott right
councillor keen here chair Thank You
councillor more
and I'm here obviously now with offices
Annabelle is Annabelle online not yet
Estelle I believe yes hello Claire thank
you
I know Emily is and I know and the
statements this afternoon will be read
out by David Stevens I'm not sure if his
long line as we speak
yes good afternoon David Lewis David
Lewis I don't know why foot Davis tea I
do apologize I should know I should know
sorry David but I am here very much
indeed thank you right thank you
oh Henry Thank You Annabelle yep
lovely thank you very much okay just a
few notes as always I think you know we
don't have a fire alarm procedure at the
moment just get out your house as quick
and if there's a fire okay if you have
any technical difficulties during the
meeting then please contact Democratic
Services Officer who's on call today it
is Charles and his telephone number is
five double seven one eight six so if
you need anything if things go wrong
that's the number to use I would ask for
participants when you are not speaking
please mute your microphone this really
minimizes any background noise if you've
got dollars and windows open it does
health microphones must be on on your
participant has been granted permission
to speak to gain permission to speak
please are very briefly indicate on the
chat to the right-hand side of your
screen and then we will make note so
back to you yes it was it's your time is
available for you but everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned off into silent and they must
not make any phone calls
during the meeting and please refrain
from checking any emails why the leting
is being carried out please note that
this meeting is being streamed live for
members of the public and following
meeting the recording will be available
on the council's YouTube channel members
resid requesting to speak under
procedure 20.1 we have counselor gamma
and counselor King on 4b is there any
other member under 25 one wishes to
speak council of white head I see he has
come up there is that under four and
often there Nick is that under four be
Helen I've been asked to speak in
relation to F / t h / 19 / 1 1 3 7 as if
this morning I'm les McDonald's new
genres of applications yep
thank you the following applications
have been reserved for public speaking
with members please note that agenda
item 4a agenda item 4b agenda item 4 D
and agenda item 4 E so there be a
statement read out on those items
agenda item 1 is apologies we do have
apologies from counselor okay his name
right lost him counselor Taylor
we have counselor recess key in for
never lost anyone counsels apologies
from counsels Dennis in your pardon and
counselor recess he is sitting beings
are there any declarations of interest
no okay thank you
agenda item three minutes of the
planning meeting held on the 29th of
April 2020
if you've read and you agree could I
have a proposal please propose it for
you our chair thank you and could I have
a seconder please
no I second that and do you all agree
thank you ma'am
point of information I'm gonna hand over
to mr. Livingston now regarding agenda
item 4b the David Copperfield at
Westwood Road and for c14 Suffolk Avenue
West Gate mr. Livingston Thank You chair
a couple of points of clarification for
members for [ __ ] item 4b the David
Copperfield our Westwood Road an
alteration is being made to condition 11
to alter the timing of the limiting of
the noise at the customer order point
from prior to the commencement of use to
within three months of the use
commencing and this is to ensure that
the timing of the assessment for the
noise level of that customer order point
is not affected by any ongoing
construction work so that the level can
be set correctly
so therefore condition 11 will now would
now read within three months of the
commencement of the use hereby permitted
the noise level of the customer
all point speakers at not 0.5 meters
shall be limited to no more than 82 DB
la EQ 1 minute this shall be
commissioned by a suitably qualified
acoustic consultant and report issued
indicating that this has been met
including an acceptable management
method for ongoing maintenance of this
limit the report should be submitted to
and approved in writing by the local
planning authority and the customer
order display facility shall be
implemented in accordance with the
approved report and thereafter
maintained and the can the ground of
that condition is to safeguard the
residential amenities currently enjoyed
by the occupiers excuse me
of nearby residential properties in
accordance with policy d1 of the Thanet
local plan so that condition has been
agreed by the council's environmental
health team also to correct an
administrative error on condition 2 on
that same item currently it states that
plan for 0d would be approved and that
should be for sorry that should be 0 6d
and this is also corrected for agenda
item 4c 14 suffolk Avenue this items
been withdrawn from consideration at
today's planning committee for public
consultation to occur regarding the
access road that runs through the site
and the ownership of that access road
Thank You chairman thank you again and
welcome to councillors Taylor I know
these meetings are often a little bit
tight for you but thank you for being
here ok moving on to our agenda item 4a
which is the plan and application for
approval of 13 Linden Avenue
Broadstairs I will get the name correct
I hope this time there is public
speaking on this application and if I
could ask Miss David Lewis to read out
the public speaking statement which is
in favor of the application which came
from a mr. Beasley saving
have we lost David mr. Stephen yes mr.
Lewis yeah thank you very
this is a baton reading of the applicant
statement Thank You chair as the
officers report quite correctly states
the council is nearing adoption of its
emerging draft local plan which will
confirm a 5.7 7 years supply of housing
land however and as accepted by the
planning inspector in the recent Appeal
decision in respect of one seven stones
drive Broadstairs that notwithstanding
the imminent local plant adoption the
housing delivery test hdt results for
2019 show only 35 percent of the target
number of homes that the government has
deemed is necessary and confirms as
critical housing supply land supply for
the council whilst the council
anticipates this situation improving
with the progression of its emerging
local plan and hdt action plan the
presumption in favor of sustainable
development at paragraph 11 bracket D
bracket of the framework nonetheless
applies the relevant policies which are
most important for determining the
application should be considered out of
date and that planning permission should
be granted unless any adverse impact of
doing so which significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits
when assessed against the policies in
this framework taken as a whole in terms
of the character and appearance of the
area it is considered that the street
scheme very street scene elevations
two members clearly demonstrate that the
proposed scheme as amended is fully in
keeping with the local areas of both
Linden Avenue and crow Hill in terms of
scale design appearance and degree of
separation and is confirmed within the
officers report similarly with regard to
living conditions enjoyed by surrounding
occupiers the officers report has gone
into extensive detail assessing each
potential impact in turn and concluding
that in all respects
there is no unacceptable harmful impact
upon residential amenity in terms of
overlooking or overshadowing the report
also quite correctly identifies where
other objections raised by neighbors
either do not constitute planning
considerations or are the subject of
control by other statutory regimes which
national planning guidance clearly
states and not to be duplicated in the
planning process in conclusion this
proposal will bring forward within a
very short space of time two additional
dwellings to assist with the council's
need to increase housing delivery in
response to the 2019 housing delivery
test figures and to contribute towards
the council achieving full compliance in
terms of satisfying housing need and to
ensuring that the adoption of the local
plan will in due course provide the
council with its five-year supply of
housing land in this instance in a
highly sustainable location within
comfortable walking and cycling
distances of all Town Center facilities
services and amenities together with
public transport routes including the
Thanet loop and Broadstairs train
station in line with the officer's
report this application is highly
commended to members for favorable
consideration thank you thank you David
as members gather that
the statement read which was written by
mr. Beasley in favor of the application
and the task David read a further
statement raising points of concern from
a mr. wallah
thank you David just reached a Thanet
planning committee I am Peter Waller a
chartered town planner and I represent
the residence of 37 and 39 crow Hill who
strongly object to the application this
is a poorly conceived proposal that
would constitute a gross over dig manner
over development to make a bottom of the
site with three family sized dwellings
poorly related to one another and to the
established pattern of development and
with no adequate private garden amenity
space the report comments that there is
variety to the design scale and
arrangement of property in the locality
and asserts that the proposals would sit
comfortably within the site and be in
keeping with the pattern of development
in the area
I strongly disagree with this analysis
while there are variations in the area
there is also a general uniformity to
the street pattern in that dwellings are
generally cited with habitable rooms
overlooking front and back garden spaces
that are not dominated by neighboring
dwellings this proposal fails to follow
this established pattern and causes
demonstrable harm to the area plot one
would lose its south-facing garden be
increased to a large 4 bedroom 2 family
house with a tiny garden and with its
south-facing habitable
rooms dominated by the five meter high
gable wall of plot 2 and only three to
four meters away plot twos 5 meter high
South flank gable would totally dominate
and overshadow the rear garden of number
28 crow hill plot 3 which is elevated
above crow hill would be sited well
forward of the building line of
neighboring dwellings and so in
combination would form an uncomfortable
dominating relationship with the street
and its neighbors furthermore this
family sized house would have no rear
garden and a tiny side garden unrelated
to the rooms in the house the report
omits to point out that these failings
would run contrary to the NPP F at
paragraph 1 to 2 to maintain an area's
prevailing character and setting
including residential gardens and
paragraph 1 to 7 which requires that
proposals are either sympathetic to
local character including the
surrounding built environment similar
views are set out in the council's own
draft local plan at policy h o1 which
only supports development of residential
gardens when not judged harmful to the
local area in terms of the character and
amenity considerations set out in policy
QD o 1q do 1 sets out general design
principles where the primary planning
aim is to reinforce the local character
and provide high quality design that
relates to surrounding development form
and the layout and is compatible with
neighboring buildings and spaces finally
policy QD o 2 requires development to be
compatible with neighboring buildings
and spaces not lead to the unacceptable
overshadowing loss of natural light or
sense of enclosure have sufficient space
to facilitate comfortable living
conditions including gardens this
proposal fails all-of-the-above policies
and should be rejected thank you sewing
peter wallah mr TPI of peter wallet
planning limited thank you very much
David I was reminded there and obviously
this isn't anything whew David normally
I think as members know there is a three
minute time limit on discussions either
from members of the public agents and so
on now we do realize that there is a
slight difficulty not being in the
chamber and so forth so I've allowed
those to carry on and I do have a
massive clock in front a meter for three
minutes but when it comes later in the
agenda to members speaking I'm going to
have to not in debate but for members
who are speaking on an application I'm
going to have to enforce that but I mean
that's at the moment with the letters
that have been written if members can
understand it is it's a little bit
difficult just to stop their their
correspondence thank you for that David
um I'll ask the planning officer to
outline this application please Thank
You chair just try and present my screen
to you hey carnival um hopefully
everybody can now see my screen yes yeah
this is an application for the extension
an alteration of number thirteen linden
avenue and for the erection of two
detached
three-bedroom dwellings within the red
line shown here as you can see from the
screen it's an irregular shape sites
application site
with Francis's frontages to both Linden
Avenue and Crow Hill this is an app
aerial photograph and the application
site is here and this is the green
garden space that we've just seen number
30 in here this is number 28 crow Hill
number 30 Grove Hill number 11 Linden
Avenue sits here with 59 linden avenue
there this is enough Afridi the issue of
the site yeah Casey on site is here we
can see Linden Avenue here and crow hill
behind zooming in again looking from
actually crow hill to the front here the
application site sits here with Linden
Avenue wrapping around I'll take you
through some photographs of the start
site and we'll start in Linden Avenue
number 13 and you can just see the edge
of number 15 a this is a zoomed in
version you can see the frontage of 15a
and 13 number 13 needs an Avenue which
is a subject of the application and it's
driveway this again from Linden Avenue
you can see number 11 Linden Avenue the
detached garages that you saw within the
site of number 13 and the white
two-story building you can see behind is
actually number 28 crow hill so we've
looked at the site as I say from Linden
Avenue in the views you get from there
so I'm going to take you through some
views from crow Hill this is the
application site number 13 here this is
its curtilage this is number 28 which we
saw the rear of from the previous
photograph and this is number 30 crow
hill looking again at the application
site here exists number 30 and we can
see the variety of dwellings within crow
hill as we look up the hill number 30 is
a shallow bungalow you can see some
two-story dwellings and that's actually
a terrace of dwellings
over here next to number 30 this is
again a shot of Chrome or you can see
both sides of the street you can see
number 30 the terrace I mentioned some
adjoining properties and this is the
application site sitting here and the
entrance to the a to number 28 so I will
actually now take you inside the site
some of these apologies share some of
these photographs are slightly darker
than we would have liked within the
garden of number 13 this is a rear
extension that would be demolished this
gives me in the application if it came
forward and this is number 30 crow hill
this is actually the rear extension
again you can see the top of number 15 a
and you can see number 13 here and this
is again a close-up between the rear
extension of number 13 and this is again
number 30 and chrome ill and this is
looking at the other side of the
application site still within the garden
of number 13 that's number 11 Linden
Avenue and this is numbers 28 and 26
grow hill and their policies this
photograph is quite dark but he shows
the side of number 13 and again number
11 and number 28 chrome Hill and this
one shows the existing side projection
that sits on number 13 with the rear
elevation extension that would be
removed sitting over to the right-hand
side and this is the rear of number 15 a
Linden Avenue and this is the
applications the poet's development you
can see number 13 which would be a
four-bedroom house number the top two as
its referred to in the report and in the
application papers would be a free
bedroom house and number plot free being
of another free bedroom house but
fronting chrome Hill there is no
objection in principle to the
development of the site the
no objections to the alterations an
extension of number 13 and there are no
objections to the development of non
previous developed land in this case
garden land due to the emerging policy
hate shown one of the draft local plan
as can be seen here block 2 faces onto
Linden Avenue and would sit to the south
of lot 13 and lot three were to face
onto chrome Hill and this is the
existing front and rear elevations of
plot 13 and these two side enter
patients and you would have seen them in
the photographs we've just looked at
this is their proposed alterations and
extensions of plot 13 we're number 13
we're looking at the front and the rear
elevation of block 13 and you can see
whilst it is described as two storeys is
essentially a chalet bungalow and it
will have rooms within the roof served
by roof flights to the rear again this
is Society elevation and the other side
elevation this the side elevation
fronting will face towards number 11 and
number 28 Crow Hill the floor plans we
have a bedroom downstairs and normal
sorry two bedrooms downstairs in this
instance and normal living space and the
upper stories there were our 2 dormers
proposed but they face the front of the
application site towards a Linden Avenue
and the other two bedrooms and
accommodation there'll be roof flights
only to the rear if we look at now plot
2 which is the plot here which is a safe
place as Linden Avenue the front
elevations are facing Linden Avenue see
there are some performers again it is a
chalet bungalow the rear elevation we've
been only roof lights at the upper floor
level the side elevation and that is
facing number 28 chrome Hill and 11
Linden Avenue and that's the other side
elevation
this is the ground floor it has a
bedroom on the lower level plus normal
living accommodation and two bedrooms
within the roof if we look at now plot
freeing this place is growing here and
again we have the front elevation with
dormer windows and a Chalet style
Shelley bungalow style building facing
onto pro Hill
this is the rear elevation again with
the upper floor only served by roof
flights we have the side elevations and
the other side elevation and that would
be the side fronting number 28 crow here
and again we have the ground floor
layout where again has a bedroom on the
ground floor as well as living
accommodation and the two bedrooms in
essentially the roof space there so it
has been noted that some concerns have
actually been raised about the
properties and their impact and how they
relate to the surrounding area the as
has been pointed out the report does go
into it quite a lot of detail and an
assessment has been made about how the
different properties and their impact
and their distances and orientation
between the diffs surrounding establish
parties and it is considered that from
officers that do to amendments that have
been made and the angles and orientation
and distances involved that there would
be no adverse impact from the minute on
the residential amenities of adjoining
occupies from these developments for
example plot 2 was slightly larger
originally and slightly less angled from
number 28 when it originally was
submitted so for example it's being made
smaller and it gives a bigger distance
between number 11 and number 28 crow
crow hill so also has been noted that
concerns were raised about the impact of
size of the garden space and amenity
spaces that have been provided for the
unit's it is correct that they may be
fairly small and and different sizes
when compared to other plots are long in
the surrounding area and it is true that
number free benefits from a limited area
to the rear but a larger side garden
when considered if we look at the block
plan looking at surrounding developments
and surrounding properties in existence
already it's not considered that they
are are any different so many of those
they're in existence already and enjoyed
by existing residents so on that basis
the application is recommended for
approval Thank You Annabelle I move that
the officers recommendation is adopted
could I have a seconder please or second
that chair Thank You councillor Coleman
cook I remember this obviously you wish
to debate this application do I see any
signs of chair if I can sorry I should
have put on the chat but I'm happy to
strip you on this please chair yeah
don't worry
councillor Albin yes please carry on
yeah Thank You chair for once I'm
actually happy with the officers report
on I don't think that there is any
demonstrable harm caused to the adjacent
properties the development in itself I
think the design is totally acceptable
both in in height and adjacent to the
neighboring buildings and and on that on
that issues on sorry on those issues
chair I'm happy to support the
application thank you Thank You
councillor Albarn councillor keen
thank you share and I just would like
some clarification for the four bed
house exactly what are the measurements
for that garden because it does look
very small can we do that Annabelle I am
fortunate I don't have the exact
measurements of the garden space to hand
but it is probably comparable to other
garden spaces within the location of
similar sized properties and at fanuc we
don't have any standard for garden sizes
it just has to it we just rely on them
being usable and we consider that that
wouldn't be a usable family space you
could play out there children could play
out there you could have your washing
out there you could have a modest
outbuilding if required so we would do
consider it to be an acceptable size
even though I don't have the exact size
for you apologies
okay thank you Thank You councillor I
can't think and well counselor job
Hayford Thank You chair um yes I can see
that efforts has been made to fit these
three properties into the space and I
don't have a problem with the design but
in view of the fact that in order to do
this one of them's had to be made
smaller and for plot three the extension
is beyond it beyond the building line I
and the building that the gardens are
tiny in my view they don't look as big
as as surrounding ones and the distance
between the property is very small I
feel this is an example of cramming I
filled up one extra house on the plot
would be much more comfortable than the
- Thank You chair thank you can also
Beaufort would you like to come back
Annabelle
well I only say that we have a system
yes it plot framing here is
approximately 2.5 meters forward of
number 30 crow hill but looking at the
wider
this if sorry this slide shows it better
but there isn't a coherent building line
a long chrome Hill property do
properties do sit in a variety of
positions so is not considered there
would be a and any impact versus impact
from it sitting slightly forward from
number 30 and as I've already reiterated
we don't have garden status garden
standards for a particular size of
dwelling
Infinite's and we do consider as office
as they are usable and freed Wellings
can fit on the site and yes amendments
have been made to plot to to make it sit
more comfortably in the site but as the
development that was put before you we
do feel it can be approved Thank You
Annabelle
councillor Hart nature I must agree with
John I do think that the plots are
certain there's a certain crammed into
the plot and do you think that this has
been brought up that we don't have a
gardens policy in the plain and that
should now be amended so that we do have
and then then properties can adhere to
some sort of garden standard councillor
ha I will jump in here if I may I think
we we've gotta stick to the point here
and obviously that could be looked at at
another stage but we're looking at this
application as it stands at the moment
yeah but I mean what I'm saying is if we
have a if we have a a garden or we're
gonna try and put something together
then surely we should have a basis by
which we look at something as a whole
because they look very crammed into that
tiny little space and I must have no
agree with Joe I think we've got to have
some sort of sense of worthiness in the
buildings we build I take on bald
councillor harp like you're saying but I
think
as another speak to officers I do
understand what you are saying so I'm
not pushing you away but I do understand
exactly what you're saying there okay
counselor as esky I thank you chair yeah
I haven't looked at these plans now and
everything I'm inclined to agree with
counselor Bay third this does seem to be
a bit of over development possibly one
on the site would have been adequate but
two is really pushing it it does leave
very small gardens and barely any room
to move around the houses by looks of it
it certainly seems that they gone
forward in the building lining crow hill
also and it's just not in character with
the whole area so personally I don't
think I could vote for this thank you
Thank You councillor Garner Thank You
chair and do you think the officer could
just show us the map of the the houses
with the gardens again please
because on pastrana Hari I heard what
she said about me there been a number of
other gardens in the area similar just
bear with us a moment please
they were Sinatra further out that
showed a number that showed up a much
wider area with all the gardens yeah
that's the one so I mean I do know the
area quite well and I walk up and down
that road I have been for my daily and
my daily walk to the stone Bay and
further up I have noticed one or two
Gardens that would be similar to the
ones that proposed but looking at that
map all of their the houses there with
the gardens so as I can see I've got
quite similar type size gardens out the
back not not sort of higgledy-piggledy
ones a little bit of the side and a
little bit at the back that's finally
calming really
cows Agana I believe councillor Alban
wishes to come back yeah Thank You chair
I think I just like to say that I think
the members mustn't get too carried away
with the gun the officers already said
that there is no policy there are no
guidelines in relation to the size of
Gardens so I think if members were
likely to want to refuse on that basis I
think you'd have a very difficult
situation appeal also chair I just
wanted to remind members that a while
ago we had an application for a row of
houses in some pieces where I personally
questioned the site the size of the
gardens which were my new in comparison
to this development and members were
happy to accept that so I just wanted to
make that comment Thank You chair no
thank you for that cancer all then and I
feel the same and that's you know I
think that this present time to go into
the situation of garden size isn't the
correct time we're dealing with an
application here and you're quite right
why you say you've seen a lot less in
gardens perhaps offices at another time
this could be looked at thank you for
that term do I have anybody else wish to
speak against the Beaufort Thank You
chair yes I accept what's been said
about garden space although absolutely
but that wasn't the only point with my
concern about cramming the houses do
thing to be pushed together as closely
as possible and it looks to me almost as
if every effort has been made to squeeze
in the extra one I'd I think we were not
only considering garden size but quality
of living and I feel that one fewer
house would make the whole development
much more comfortable thank you - Thank
You councillor Beaufort
I can't see anybody else who wishes to
speak so
I'm going to put this to the vote and I
will go through your names obviously and
if you could say for against or abstain
it would be grateful so I will start
with council a common cook for
councillor Albin fourth year councillor
favored against you councillor curry for
chair Thank You councillor Rose esky
against chair council the Duckworth for
Thank You councillor garner against
councillor heart against councillor keen
for I don't think we have councillor
more with us still correctly if I'm
wrong
councillor recess key I've done I think
yes I think I did you count stories squ
up has you disappeared I J yes you've
done me I think it's alright it's
doubled up on my paper here don't worry
thank you accounts of Scots yep poor
chair thank you I didn't realize you
were there Thank You Matthew
councillor Taylor for comes the right
before thank you and looking down here I
believe that motion is carried
Thank You members and I'm sure Emily
will yeah she has agreed so there's a
carry thank you very much
moving on to item agenda for be there
are several statements to be read to you
here which I'm going to go back to David
the officer will read out of public
speaking that the statement in
favor of the application from a mr. Fox
so they even if you do that please
Thank You chair this reads thank you for
allowing us the opportunity to provide a
written statement in these truly
exceptional times the proposal before
you seeks to convert the former david
copperfield harvest a restaurant which
has been vacant since April 2019 we seek
to maintain the family feel dining area
inside and incorporating a convenient
drive-through for passing motorists
given the current national situation the
proposed economic stimulus this proposal
will have cannot be downplayed when
normality finally returns the proposal
seeks to bring back to life a former
restaurant on a brownfield site in a
suitable and sustainable location
adjacent to the existing KFC and
westward road we want to take this
opportunity to reiterate our commitment
to invest in Broadstairs for the long
term providing an attractive frontage
foot for and at least 65 jobs for local
people the restaurant will be locally
franchised which will inherently provide
additional benefits to the local area
local franchisee Paul Crocker actively
supports local initiatives including the
charity litter angels and also
sponsoring Senate Colts football team
Paul's wider commitment to the local
community has been more evident than
ever during the coronavirus crisis
distributing stock when his restaurants
closed in March to Kent and Medway NHS
and Social Care Partnership trust and
other good causes across East Kent as a
company McDonald's invests sorry invest
over forty three million pounds a year
in staff training all of our employees
have access to a range of
vacations to help them develop including
nationally-recognized foundation degrees
and apprenticeships the majority of our
managers started serving in our
restaurants as did many of our most
senior staff we work very hard to make
sure the area so sorry around our
restaurant is litter free last year we
launched keep up the clean up a little
picking campaign during which we carried
out over 450 cleanups including in
Thanet we continue to support Keep
Britain Tidy and their great British
spring clean staff at all our
restaurants carry out a minimum of three
daily cleanups in the immediate area
picking up all litter not just
McDonald's packaging we have worked hard
with officers during the course of the
application to ensure the proposal
before you is in an acceptable form we
are seeking to provide for electric
vehicle charging points and to keep
clear box at the entrance to the site in
addition we have enhanced the landscape
boundary along Westwood Road and will
ensure this is well maintained during
the life of the development a three
meter acoustic fence is proposed along
the southern boundary and we have also
agreed to close off the southern carpark
area with bollards during later hours we
have also agreed to limit the opening
hours of the restaurant following
careful consultation with the council's
Environmental Health Officer there are
many benefits that the proposed scheme
will bring and we are excited to bring
the former David Copperfield back to
life providing a significant economic
investment into the whole area which
will provide a range of benefits to the
local community we are pleased with the
officers recommendation and we trust you
can now support the application thank
you thank you David I'm going to ask
David now to speak on behalf of the miss
Mackenzie who is ranking points of
concern
statement by Karen McKenzie the
application by McDonald's to make this a
fast-food restaurant with drive-through
food collection point may contribute to
the obesity epidemic of this country and
this area in particular since we already
have a McDonald's less than a mile away
at Westwood cross perhaps councilors may
not be aware of the stats or may choose
to believe that a nanny state should not
get involved in dictating how people
choose to eat to the first point here
are some shocking statistics I will
discuss the nanny state angle after this
here's the stats one in four adults are
classed as obese and a further 62% are
overweight
this makes Britain the highest sorry the
second highest rate of obesity in the
world and the highest in Europe not
something to be proud of is it 48
million pounds is spent managing the
social causes and health care of obesity
morbid obesity rates have almost tripled
since 1993 and between 1993 and 2000 the
McDonald's chain has grown to more than
1,000 locations in the UK why on earth
do we need another one here we just
don't there is already sorry there
already is one less than a mile away and
so to my second point
perhaps you perhaps we should not be a
nanny state and control whether people
can eat at this new restaurant even
without getting out of their car we can
choose to eat Big Macs as part of a
normal diet right well let's say we
order a super mais super-sized Big Mac
and fries with a milkshake as part of a
normal diet this meal alone is one
thousand five hundred and sixty-six
calories compared to an adult
requirement of two thousand for the
whole day so what about children the ONS
states that even in reception class 20%
of children are now overweight and a
whopping 26 percent in year six
a four-foot 8 10 year old who is
overweight and the couch potato only
needs 1028 calories for the whole day
that's 538 calories over the top in one
meal and if they are active instead they
still only need 1318 calories and one
Big Mac meal is too much already for the
whole day so even for active kids Big
Macs are bad news
why on earth do you think that it's
different in Fannett it's not remember
this venue is opposite one school and
very near to three others that's why
they want the site undoubtedly it's a
choice to eat at McDonald's but the food
is very cheap and is attractive to kids
who are unable to make sensible
decisions for themselves and since only
13% of the population in the country are
normal weight
it seems adults are finding that
decision difficult to so in conclusion I
would remind counselors that you are in
a position to help improve the lives of
the people in thinit
by considering the wider impacts of
granting this application people can
still choose the KFC drive-through next
door or go to the McDonald's on Westwood
cross if they want but we really don't
need another temptation directly
opposite to school and really near to
others please refuse this application
and before I finish I think I read out a
statistic as 48 million is spent in fact
it's 48 billion is spent managing the
social causes and health care of obesity
so apologies for that error thank you
thank you David very much once again
members as you gather that went over
three minutes but we have allowed I have
allowed the statements that have been
sent in via email or letter it is a
difficult one to stop and I think we've
all learned something with that last
comment speaking under council procedure
20.1
councillor whitehead good afternoon all
I've been asked to attend to raise
concerns expressed by a constituent
would it be appropriate to read her
statement at this point yes please I'm
sorry Helen you have three minutes I've
got you with councillors thank you yeah
of course um we have a statement here
buy it miss Garfield I am writing to
express my outrage at the proposed
McDonald's restaurant which is going to
replace the former David Copperfield
restaurant in Broadstairs which is
located along the walking route to st.
George's secondary school according to
the World Health Organization in the UK
ranks third in the European obesity
table where 27.8% of its population are
clinically obese public health England
report that 60% more children in their
last year of primary school are
classified as severely obese than in
their first year indeed Jeremy Hunt a
former health secretary warns that UK
school children were now fatter than
those in America furthermore the trend
continues three-quarters of men and
two-thirds of women will be overweight
by 2030 a report in 2019 highlighted
that the terms in Kent had the most of
these children new figures from the
child measurement program revealed that
500 for children of year 6 pupils in the
area were cast as overweight or obese
representing an astounding 37 percent of
the total in Thanet 14% of children aged
10 to 11 a classified as overweight 20%
of obese and 5% of severely obese
these figures are alarming and show no
signs of abating the NHS chief executive
Simon Stevin said obesity is a dangerous
public health threat for our children
leading to a string of serious illnesses
these appalling figures show that we are
clearly not on track to meet the
government's sensible goal for having a
childhood obesity
professor Dame Parveen Kumar board of
science chair of the British Medical
Association said that it's a tragedy
that so many children are being exposed
to in tempted by junk food jeopardizing
the healthy start in life they
in a similar vein a report by former
chief medical officer professor Dame
Sally Davies has called for tougher
action on obesity saying snacks should
be banned and called for tighter rules
and advertising and takeaways as a
nation we are all aware of the
Associated health risks attributed to
obesity I'll cancel have a duty to do
the right thing if we care about the
health of our children we need to
protect them from the source of harm
that could damage their health citing a
fast-food chain restaurant and the
doorstep of school is a responsible and
morally reprehensible
Society will must have endeavoured to do
the right thing even if it may be seen
as unpopular with certain members of the
public I very much hope all councils
will take heart of what I've said
consider the consequences and vote
against the decision to install them a
doll's restaurant at this site at a time
when the Prime Minister stated there is
an urgent need to tackle Britain's
obesity problem the granting of another
fast-food burger and chiptune close to a
school is not conducive to attaining
this and she wishes to Sport Mike garner
in calling in the application that's a
statement by Miss Donna Garfield Thank
You counselor I had bang on three
minutes well done thank you if I can
call on the board counselor counselor
garner please thank you
thank you very much if this application
is passed that would see another
McDonald's drive-through restaurant less
than a mile away from their existing
outlet in Westwood and less than 400
meters from the gates of st. George's
the Church of England school as you will
see this application has been opposed by
a significant number of local residents
whose eyes will be impacted if this were
to go ahead and it should also be noted
that 136 people have signed a petition
calling for this application to be
rejected the development will send its
significant increase in traffic through
the single entry and exit point to the
estate already used by customers arroz
de and KFC as well as increase in the
risk of road traffic accidents this is
likely to result in an increase in air
pollution which will impact on the lives
of not just local residents
but also children a staff attending the
local school use me recently searched by
global action plan and the British Heart
Foundation has shown school children are
already been exposed to 30% more
particulate pollution compared to adults
from walking along busy roads this
proposal will exacerbate the situation
the development will likely see an
increase in antisocial behavior in the
area as noted by CEM police in their
submission and I'm surprised that a
number of their recommendations seem to
have been ignored in favor of relying
solely on the installation of CCTV
cameras as a main method of deterrence
the development will see an increase in
both noise levels and fool odor levels
from the site neither of which can be
can control to an acceptable level to
satisfy either policy q do three of the
drive local plan all policy SEO six
despite the recently proposed 60
centimeter increase to the height of the
proposed fence bordering unfilled Road
houses while the houses themselves may
be 40 meters from the building their
gardens run up to the proposed fence and
residents can't be expected to stay
indoors to invert avoid the increase in
noise and odors finally on surprise of
public health issues highlighted by the
Environmental Health Team don't seem to
have been considered when making the
recommendation to approve local plan
policy TC knowing states that new
applications for hot food takeaways
should be judged against the
sensitivities of the neighborhood I
believe the very close proximity to the
said George is school and the closest
other schools is in contravention of
this as well as policy SP 36 in the
draft local plan which seeks to improve
the health of Planets residents and
reduce health inequalities our local
plan recognizes a need to promote
healthy lifestyle as we know that the
increase in obesity levels raises a risk
of other health issues including type-2
diabetes heart disease and now
coronavirus and I hope you will consider
this and all the other reasons too
this application Thank You counselor
Ghana although a member of the planning
committee councillor Keene has asked to
speak under twenty point one so
councillor Keene Thank You chair having
read all the supporting documents I
firmly believe this is the wrong
proposal in the wrong place at the wrong
time there are many practical objections
already raised by the public such as the
impact on the residents of rum Field
Road extra noise and smells increase in
traffic on an already busy road the
potential for it to become a hangout for
young people and possible antisocial
behavior these are concerning enough but
you may feel a sufficiently addressed in
the document or through the discussion
and debate that will follow but my
overriding concern is the health impact
I was uncertain as to how much health
could be a consideration in assessing a
planning proposal but discovered that it
is strongly embedded in planning policy
one of the core principles of the
national planning policy framework is
that it should take account of and
support local strategies to improve
health and work with public health leads
the national planning practice guidance
on health and well-being supports
policies to limit the proliferation of
certain uses which would include
fast-food to create a healthier food
environment this proposal would cite the
McDonald's directly opposite one senior
school and in close proximity to two
others although it is our drive-through
it is clearly not targeting drivers as
there is an already established
McDonald's with the drive-through less
than a mile up the road Westwood cross
an easy driving distance McDonald's have
improved their menu to include healthier
options but a fast-food burger and fries
is not a healthy option the Golden M is
one of the most recognizable science
there is and that is what children will
see before and after school you may
think this is an issue of freedom of
choice but families already have this
choice a mile up the road this is
targeting a particular audience and it
matters we have an obesity problem in
Thanet Sport England recently released
figures showing that sixty eight point
four percent of adults
in Thanet are overweight or obese the
highest in Kent alongside Swale and fast
food is part of this
there are many initiatives to address
this than some of them involve planning
many London boroughs have policies
preventing new fast-food outlets opening
within 400 metres of schools this
proposal is literally opposite to school
this proposal does not benefit our
population please consider this in your
debate my belief is wrong proposal wrong
place wrong time
spot on time ago and thank Thank You
councillor Keene I'm gonna hand over to
mr. Levinson who will give the report
Thank You Eman I'm just going to present
my screen now
can all members still hear me yes
excellent so the application is for the
change of use of an a3 restaurant to a
mixed-use a3 and restaurant and a5 which
is hot food takeaway with external
changes to the building including
demolition and a single story extension
reconfiguration of parking and road
layout as well as a new boundary fencing
so the site is outlined in red on the
westward road and this is an aerial
image of the site with the former David
Copperfield in the center of the image
so the main issues for members to
consider with this application are the
principle of development the impact on
the living conditions of neighboring
properties the impact on the character
appearance of the area impact on highway
safety and there are another of other
matters that have been raised by that
the speeches this afternoon and just to
note that we've received a couple of
additional objections to this
application since the agenda was
published and they raised the queries
about the question of need for the hot
food takeaway element and public health
concerns which I'll come on to in the
presentation so in terms of the location
of the development it sits adjacent to
an existing hopefully takeaway
restaurant which is the KFC located just
the right-hand side of the image just
looking at some of the sort of isometric
views of the site location so you can
see Rumsfeld Road is behind the site so
you can see the the residential area on
the left-hand side of the image you can
see the car park which is for the Asda
store and then
going round to the other angle you can
see some George's school which is
obviously been mentioned in the on the
right hand side of the image and the
Christchurch buildings to the the top of
the image there and then this is just a
view from looking from Rumsfeld roads so
you can see the back of the existing
David Copperfield building and opposite
the site you have the open fields which
cause which is part of the green wedge
between Margate and Broadstairs
so just to go through some photos of the
sites so this is a view from Westwood
Road of the existing building then
looking back towards the the site from
further along closer to San George's
School so you can see the the KFC
property in the background there I'll
take you through the external iterations
in a little bit when we look at the
plans but just to note that there are as
a demolition of this element here as
indicated by the mouse pointer as well
as the gable ended single storey
extension here with a single storey
extension in on this elevation of the
property proposed and this is a view
from further on down westward Road of
the building in situ this is just
another image just showing the entrance
to the existing building on the front of
Westwood Road so now I'm going to go
into the site so looking at the from
from actually within the access road
that leads into the site no this is a
view of the back elevation of the
building so you can see that the
claddings actually changed colour as you
go around to the back of the building
and there's one of the previous
entrances used for the David Copperfield
on the left-hand side of the image and
then turning to the left to look at the
other in data that is that the current
building Institute
and then turning again to the left this
is an existing car parking area that the
currently serves as sort of an overflow
parking for both the David Copperfield
and also for for KFC and in fact you can
see that there's a there's a refuse bin
there from from KFC in it and you can
see at the moment this is open and
accessible at the moment with CCTV in it
so just doing some use of the road
network just around this part here
because one of the issues that members
to consider is the impact on the highway
safety so this is a view from further
back looking at the access road that
leads to both KFC and the existing david
copperfield building so the carpark that
we were just looking at is on the left
hand side here in terms of the access
and then just to turn to the right so
you can see again the the KFC building
and then this is a view looking from the
access road with KFC off to the left
looking back towards the junction with
the internal road that leads to Asda so
some members may be familiar with that
but just give you the the context of
what's being looked at so in terms of
the existing site this is just showing
the extent of the building on the site
at the moment and in terms of the
proposal was proposed to occur is the
demolition of the element on the corner
as as mentioned with then a single-story
extension that would come out to
effectively serve the restaurants
kitchen facilities so as you can see
from this plan what's being proposed is
to create a drive-thru route around the
the building which would then which
would run along the back of the
boundaries onto a road and also on the
side of the restaurant for wrapping
around and back into a parking area and
the overflow parking area would be
remodeled with new lines being painted
in terms of the the parking allocation
for for that area
so just to pick up a couple of the
points that have been raised looking at
the principle of the development I think
it's important to state a few points one
is that in terms of an application being
made it's not a consideration for the
local planning authority about the
intentions of an applicant and I think
that's just important to state that in
terms of four members considering this
application um if the current premises
are is a commercial commercial property
in a small retail park element which is
obviously and it's also adjacent to a
hot food takeaway and there is no
requirement when you're changing the use
from a a commercial premises to another
commercial premises within the retail
use classes there's no requirement under
local policy to require any sort of
sequential test or a test of need for
the development so in terms of the
proximity to this site of an additional
restaurant by the particular particular
company that's not a matter that's
enshrined in planning policy for a
consideration for members as a negative
against this application and also whilst
McDonald's are the applicant it's for
members to consider the use proposed
particularly the the restaurant and hot
food takeaway elements and the impacts
of that use and so it's about
considering the evidential impacts of
that use and not the brand itself um in
terms of picking up the particular
points and concerns that have been
raised by speakers and also in the
points that the council has received the
site does sit in in close proximity with
sin George's School as well as or seek
to the right of the image that you can
see the day in court Grammar School and
this is picked up particularly in the
report in terms of considering the
public health impacts now this is looked
at by a number of local authorities by
when there are particular specific
locations where there are public health
issues and there is a concentration of
uses in close proximity
the school in specific areas of
deprivation and and what local
authorities are required to do under the
national planning policy of practice
guidance is effectively put forward
planning policies to control certain
uses in those area is a particular issue
in this instance there is no local plan
policy with regards to a a specific
restriction on hot food takeaways in
this location and therefore it needs to
be considered on its own merits and on
the basis of that evidence it's not the
view of officers that this would result
in over concentration of hot food
takeaways There is obviously a hot food
takeaway directly next door and it this
is in a small retail park area so the
actual principle of a commercial use in
this area is considered to be acceptable
and as mentioned in terms of the
specific concerns that been raised with
regards to obesity
there is no planning policy restricting
the location and the development is not
considered a result in a demonstrable
harm to public health in this particular
area this particular area is not rewards
and peace is not not a deprived Ward in
terms of the indebt indices of
deprivation and it's not considered that
there is a location specific harm that
this would cause but it has been
considered and it's it's it is noted
obviously the proximity to the school
and this has been taken into account
however it's not considered to result in
sufficient harm or an evidential harm to
result in a refusal of the application
however what must be considered as
impact on neighboring properties because
this is the key issue when considering
hot food takeaways and so officers look
at this with with quite a lot of details
specifically with regards to the
environmental health seem have been
heavily involved and so some changes
have been made to the proposal including
limiting the opening hours now those
opening hours would be limited to closed
11:00 p.m. and then open at 3:00 a.m.
with the potential previously put
forward for 24 hour opening
now the restriction of the hours to
those times is not sufficient on its own
it requires a number of other mitigation
measures to be put in place to avoid a
harmful impact on the neighboring
parties so they include restricting the
use of the carpark which is on the
right-hand side of the image the of the
carpark and so that could only be used
between 7:00 a.m. and 9:00 p.m. because
that car park is in closer proximity to
neighbors on Rumsfeld Road than those
neighbors that are adjacent to the
actual restaurant itself and one of the
key elements of the mitigation is also
the three meter high acoustic fence
which would run all the way along the
rear boundaries of the properties on
Rumsfeld Road details of that fence
would have to be submitted and approved
prior to the commencement at private
commencement of the use and it would
have peace to the satisfaction of the
environmental health team in terms of
noise specifically there are it's also
proposed for limits on the noise from
equipment and plant as well as
restrictions on the noise from the
customer order displays of the of the
actual take away aspect of the drive
through in terms of looking at the other
potential impacts of this development in
terms of odor an odor assessment has
been submitted with the application and
there is a specific condition which is
proposed on the on the the any any
approval which is condition 3 which is
required requiring certain measures
detailed in that plan to be enacted in
full it also includes specific reference
to the need for any extraction flow to
terminate above 1 meter above the Eve's
high and discharge vertically at a
specific velocity again to avoid an
impact in terms of odor and
environmental for very keen to make sure
that covered the actual external areas
of the properties on Rumsfeld Road so
not just the actual premises the
properties themselves and that also
includes a measure such as the the
carbon filters in the extraction needing
to be changed every six months to ensure
that they are
doing their their job in terms of air
quality is that when mentioned as well
it is proposed to have for electric
vehicle charging points and
environmental are happy that that would
deal with the issues in terms of the a
qu ma and and therefore on the impact on
neighboring properties it is considered
that the development has dealt with
those issues sufficiently but that only
comes through the insert through the
imposition of specific conditions so
moving through the the changes
externally that are proposed to the
premises as mentioned there are certain
features that are being removed from the
building that are currently present so
in terms of the elevation of France
Western Road and what's being proposed
is that the cladding that's currently at
first for all level will be painted
slate gray and the brickwork will just
be repaired where necessary following
certain elements the building being
removed so the the single-story a sort
of accretions that are present and in
terms of the side elevation also known
as the rear elevation which currently
has an entrance door into the premises
it's a third entrance door and so this
is where the extension would would be
proposed with it's a triangular
extension so this elevation is a flat
version of that elevation but it's not
considered that it's significantly
obtrusive in the area
given its single-story nature and the
materials that have been proposed which
include a rendered face of the building
is not considered to be out of character
with the area again in terms of the
existing elevation and then the proposed
so again what's being posed here is the
painting of the of the first-floor
cladding with alterations to the
fenestration of ground floor and then
the rear end of the building sort of a
more functional aspect again that's
being some of the openings are being
removed as part of the proposal
so just looking through the floor plans
the development this is the existing
floor plan of the the current restaurant
we can see the bar area of present and
so what's being proposed is that the
extension comes out which is where the
kitchen facilities are covered the
dotted lines on this image are the
previous layout which has to be removed
so you can see that the layout has
mostly dining facilities then with the
actual counters being a small area in in
the vicinity where the mouse pointer is
here and then including the first floor
plans there is there are no proposes
made to the first floor useful layout
and other than some of the windows are
being blocked up which are on the
right-hand side of the image the members
can see just a couple of other points
particularly with regards to highways
and concerns have been raised about the
impact on the sort of mean roundabout
this on the west would road and KCC
highways been consulted and and come
back and forth about the proposal a
requirement that's been asked for by KCC
is for a keep clear road markings to be
provided prior to the usage commencing
to ensure that any any any people
wanting to turn right when coming into
off that mean roundabout into the sort
of retail area and that they can do that
unobstructed and case you see how I've
looked at the evidence around there and
consider that is sufficient to avoid
significant backing up in particular
times in the day as well as that the
proposal is considered to provide enough
car parking and also highways have
looked at the internal layout of the
drive through to ensure that that
doesn't result in any particular
concerns that would impact on the
network as well as that there are
conditions imposing requirements on a
delivering servicing management plan to
be provided specifically to ensure that
there are
impacts from deliveries being made and
obviously that would include looking at
issues to do with timings to avoid any
impact on neighbors as well as a
construction management plan because
just to avoid construction words
affecting the network so overall it is
considered that the development would
have benefits of bringing an existing
vacant commercial premises back into use
and it is considered by officers that
the principle the development is
acceptable in this location the proposal
has dealt with multiple concerns raised
by environmental health and highways and
therefore it would be subject to
multiple conditions and mainly that is
to make sure that the impact on the
neighbors is is sufficiently mitigated
and therefore the recommendation is is
for approval Thank You chair Thank You M
I put to you that the officers
recommendation is for approval could I
have a seconder please of second that
you thank also common Cook I have
councillor Alban wishes to speak and
thank you
mr. Livingstone for is for going through
that that application with us and I
suppose the old David Copperfield was an
eat-in restaurant not a takeaway and I
can see I can see the benefit of having
a further restaurant there whether it be
a takeaway as well as eating in
initially they say about could be up to
65 jobs I don't take too much with that
probably a lot of them are be zero hours
of part-time so I'm not particularly
persuaded by by the job allocation and
I'm also not particularly persuaded by
the by the comments of some of the
residents in relation to obesity etc
that
that is a matter of choice I don't think
that's something that we could take it
to account here although I do have
extreme concern about the children from
the school accessing the restaurant the
take away part however my main concern
for this application is in relation to
the adjacent residential properties and
the effect that this development will
have on them in particular noise smell
an anti-social behavior and while still
living in an outlined the issues of the
of overcoming possibility of the smelly
mission affecting of the residents and
an acoustic fence mark my concern is
that young and young people of this area
will will attend here they park their
vehicles there they were ever allowed
music there they will leave their their
take away within their cars and it will
be a meeting place and I do have
concerns about that chair and and I do
have concerns about the effect that it
will have on it because it won't just be
a one-off thing it will be an ongoing
issue so those are my concerns and I
went to you what other members have to
say to you thank you thank you Council
when and I wish I'm saying wish come
back yes thank you check just to come
back on the antisocial behavior point
and I didn't actually mention this in
the presentation so I think it's worth
it's worth touching on this as it's been
mentioned um the the overflow car
parking area was one of the major
concerns that was raised by both
environment health and also the police
now what's been proposed here is is to
deal with that in part through bollards
which would restrict the use with the
therefore almost opening hours that
would restrict the access to that
particular
area now at the moment that area is is
can be used unimpeded and obviously this
is directly opposite an existing hot
food takeaway so it's not considered by
officers that this particular use would
would result an impact that the
significantly exceeds the existing
situation that that could occur from the
existing coffee take away being being
present with greater controls over that
particular parking area as well through
through this application Thank You chair
Thank You Anne councillor Taylor but it
first it all that come out that we're
all slight in McDonald's because I don't
think no I locking the doors just as
much as anybody now and again on the on
the other site in Westwood I think that
is perfectly upend outside you've got a
good parking area it's well accessed
from everybody the drive-thru works well
and so does the restaurant here I just
feel in my own opinion I Drive through
another Drive through here and I'm good
to KFC next door it's just not right
I've just it's more vehicle traffic and
end of the day it's supposed to be a
restaurant not like not a takeaway and
and also I do worry cars mystery
lewiston about the Carteret help is
there gonna be a force not in force but
that sort of how they're gonna place the
cars that are queuing up and maybe not
turning off their engines I mean this
got obviously goes for the KFC for
obviously that's probably saying in
place already but I just wanted how is
this gonna be police with the fumes that
could affect in the near neighborhood
can you answer that in um well there
isn't any form of specific policing
that's been proposed in terms of of the
development and in terms of um the
impact of issues to their quality from
result of the drive-through that has
been looked as I mentioned by um
our health team and in terms of where
the the drive-through is located in
terms of fumes affecting me the
building's themselves of the neighbors
it's not considered that there's going
to be a specific harm by virtue of the
distance in terms of the impact on the
actual sort of garden areas there is
also significant distance for the vast
majority of the gardens from the
premises as well as well as obviously
the barrier that's that's being created
in terms of managing actual traffic flow
again that's not something that is
required with developments such as this
and indeed obviously it's an existing
access used by premises not only the
hockey takeaway but obviously the
overall access road is used by Asda
which obviously generates a significant
number of Vick Euler movements and so
kcz highways have looked at the
movements on highway safety and do not
consider that there are evidential
grounds to object so therefore it's not
being put forward as a concern by by
officers okay and a councillor Duckworth
oh yeah I just like to okay some of the
things that cats the urban and cats of
Taylor have been saying I'm concerned
about the local residents the amount of
noise that be created to be intensified
by having being open really slightly
less than 24 hours today there is that
four hours when they would shut but does
that mean that people just hanging
around when it's so open
I think there could be implications for
anti-social behavior and indeed
generally the emissions from fuels even
if they don't specifically affect
neighbors they're going to put up the
emissions in in the area and generally
that's not good for fun it Thank You
councillor Currie
there we go Thank You chair
yeah I looked at the residents
objections and heard members thoughts I
do believe that as it stands this
development would have a detrimental
effect on local people noise odors and
extra environmental issues and these are
all a real concern for me health issues
so once I Dan dive being mentioned by
many members the the effects on
residents is also an issue for me thank
you very much chair
thank you Matt caster curry counselor
right mr. chairman
I believe we've been here four years ago
with minister and the world was going to
come to an end because of the McDonald's
it didn't I will like to remind all all
members that this is a planning
application not to change abuse
application but you're forgetting with
the former david copperfield was a
restaurant bar I worked in a star
for quite long time and believe me the
noise and the anti-social behavior that
came from the pub will was will be was
far greater than anything you're going
to get from the McDonald's I think that
the you say you're safe these some of
the objectors say it's only a mile away
from the other McDonald's that's if you
walk towards Tesco's if you go in the
opposite direction it's to at least two
miles away from the other two schools
lots of your fact the facts and figures
that I understand the obesity and the
worry are all based on children under 10
these children and Georgia's are young
adults they're not children and I think
that they are very conscious about what
they ate thank you Thank You councillor
right cancer assess key
thank you sure yeah don't noted what
people have said it is a planning
application when they're talking about
the extra mile to Westwood cross to get
to the McDonald's there you must
remember the people who say Peters and
brawl says have to drive that extra mile
in thick traffic to get to that
McDonald's causing more fumes etc and
it's a mile back again so that's two
miles that having to do extra there's
always a queue at the one in Westwood
cross I think but this would alleviate
the situation there and improve their
quality in any case so I will be
supporting you thank you
Thank You councillor is SEO council
common cook thank you
what doesn't seem to have been mentioned
is the fact that KFC anyone that's been
to Asda at school throwing out time
we'll see that KFC is packaged with
schoolchildren this KFC not give you a
beastie I don't know the amount smell
and traffic for KFC is a fair amount
anyway and as Council a right said with
the old restaurant there is a huge
amount of noise and anti-social
behaviour I personally think that this
this is a planning application not an
obesity application and I personally
think that if this goes to appeal they
will get it and it would just cost us
even more money so I shall be supporting
it thank you care Thank You councillor
Coleman cook in at thank each other I
just wanted to come back on a one on one
of the points that's been raised in the
guards to impact on neighbors which I
know is a concern of members
and this is something that has been
looked at a lot of detail and the
application has has basically been held
for a while whilst those issues are
being resolved before putting it in
front of members and the environmental
health team have looked at the evidence
available and in their professional view
consider that on the basis of the
conditions that would have to be imposed
it would result in an acceptable impact
in terms of on neighboring properties
and so that that issue has been resolved
in terms of the evidence and the
professional guidance that they provide
to us so just wanted to state that fact
Thank You chair Thank You en Casa de
Beauford Thank You chair just to say
that I I agree with them with things
have been said previously we must be
voting on this in the planning reasons
alone not moral or health issues thank
you Thank You councillor de cáncer right
I want to come back just a quick you mr.
chairman as a measure of interest what
how many complaints do I made about the
deliveries to and fro most are but their
deliveries are through the night and
they are very large double-decker
lorries thank you I think I'll come in
there again counselor right um not sure
really weather this again I understand I
know where the site is and so forth um I
don't think this really is you know
regarding this application is relevant
no it's just that noise levels level was
from the deliveries at Asda are through
the night
they're not just thing and I don't think
you get very many complaints about that
so I don't see what the impact to take
away would have to make it different
that's all no I totally understand where
you're coming from there I mean you know
that to Ian with a has any comment on
um I think as a general point obviously
the the existing commercial area that
both KFC and Asda clear does generate
movements throughout the day which will
include deliveries
I've seen in terms of this proposal what
has been required again is for a
delivery and servicing management plan
to be provided to be assessed by both
highways and also council officers to
ensure that we are avoiding any
unnecessary you know or undue impact on
on residential properties adjacent thank
you
Thank You Ian I can't see any other
speakers at all so I'm going to put this
to you to the vote and I know you're
aware that councillor Ghana and
councillor keen cannot vote on this so I
run through the names once again for
against or your abstaining so cancer
common cook for count Robin the games
count the bay furred for cancer parable
against councillor resist key for
councillor Duckworth against councillor
heart for count some more we don't have
accounts as Scott has left councillor
Taylor against counts are right for and
I'm for it as well so we have
for I'm looking at Emily if that motion
has been carried or lost the motion is
carried
Thank You members Jerry thank you for
the debate
sorry yeah mr. Carr can I have my can I
have my view noted please chair totally
understand thank you kept rollin
I'm sure Emily will do that interesting
debate and a totally understand what
we've heard this afternoon are the
concerns of I think all of us have had
various emails from concerned people as
well so anyway thank you for that all
right moving on
just get my paperwork in the right
correct or if I may counts agenda item
4d that's right because we had a change
which is at the land between Madison
Road and Preston Road joining Manson
green industries
this is feet for deferral I'm going to
ask David if he could read out
statements once again statement the
first statement will be in favor of the
application from mr. banks thank you
David
Thank You chair this reads F oblique th
stroke 19 stroke Oh 438 mixed use
residential and business development at
land between Manston Road and Preston
Road for joining monster and green
industries Manston CT 12 v aax addressed
to committee by realist planning
solutions on behalf of Messersmith and
montgomery good afternoon
as members have been advised the site is
a subject of an extant outline
permission for
mixed-use residential stroke commercial
scheme previously approved by members of
this committee the application now
before you will deliver a bespoke policy
compliant development providing high
quality family homes including the full
30 percent affordable housing provision
in this regard members are advised that
advanced discussions have taken place
between the applicants and a local
affordable housing provider who will
ensure that the 8 affordable family
homes are delivered and made available
for occupation prior to the delivery of
any of the market homes in addition the
delivery of high-quality small-scale
employment floor space for small
business startups and local
entrepreneurs will improve employment
provision locally and meet with a number
of local and national planning policy
provisions that seek to encourage growth
in rural areas importantly the proposal
will deliver the shop throat cafe that
was considered essential by members of
the planning committee when considering
the outlined scheme your officers have
now been provided with a section 106
obligation that sets out how the shop
stroke Cafe will be delivered in a
timely manner and prior to the full
occupation of the development not only
will the shop stroke cafe improve
customer sorry consumer choice within
the rural area it will enhance community
provision complimenting the facilities
at the village hall the views of the
parish council and local people are
disappointing given firstly the lack of
objection to the initial outlined scheme
and secondly the fact that the joint
applicant sought to engage with the
parish at a very early stage in the
process the access Arrangements as
originally proposed were revised in
order overcome the concerns of locals
including those of mr. Tritton and mr.
Matthews the scheme proposes overspill
parking for the village hall and more
than compensates for the loss of on
street parking
again proposed to meet locals concerns
an experienced and highly reputable
ecologist has confirmed that the
development will not adversely impact
upon protected species or their habitats
and those few trees to be removed have
been identified as being at the end of
their lifespan in any event the
applicants understand that people are
frightened of change not only in
relation to the physical environment but
in terms of changes to their community
however they have worked hard with the
community and your own officers in
seeking to deliver a sustainable
mixed-use scheme which members are now
asked to consider favorably given the
officers recommendation thank you thank
you David we'll be coming back to you
when regarding a public speaking a
statement has been issued with points of
concern from mr. Triton over to you
again David thank you thank you Jeff
statement by mr. Triton please find
enclosed my objections to the above
development the road layout the proposed
entrance to the Cafe stroke shop is on
the narrowest section of the road and
blind Bend even if remove of sections of
the hedge is removed this will still
cause problems yellow lines in Preston
Road will cause parking problems for the
village hall users as they will have to
park in front of the LEAs making it
harder for residents to park pedestrian
no path on one side of the road if you
put a new parking you are going narrow
the road even more removal of trees and
hedges in Preston Road and the site
itself will major impact on the wildlife
in the area it is also my worry that the
shop and will not survive and will be
converted into accommodation and that's
the end of that statement
thank you David
now ask the planning officer to give the
report please Thank You chair I'll just
present my screen Thank You Annabelle
hopefully members can see my screen now
we have the application site outlined in
red and the application is a mixed-use
development a full application for 28
dwellings and 18 b1 office units and
together with a shop and Stroke cafe
this is the application site assay
outlined in red it comes down here wraps
around Menston green farm and comes
along to a point long preston road here
this is an aerial view of the
application site it sits here and wraps
around this is Manston Green farm this
is the green we have Preston Road and
man Stan Road coming off here enough of
you looking at the site the application
site is here this little bit here and
then wraps around and comes out along
Preston Road enough of you of the
application site and you can see the
curve of man stand Road coming round
here this is the application site this
is the old village hall for points of
reference and the application site wraps
around this part of it a long side man
stone green farm on to Preston Road here
it sort of cuts out about halfway
between here and the old village hall
and there is a small section here
adjacent to the green where two
bungalows are proposed members will note
that the application site is quite
shielded by vegetation this is a
footpath that runs but a long sorry
between Preston Road and Manston Road
and as you can see there's quite a lot
of landscaping here and there are four
points of landscaping along Preston Road
and surrounding the application site in
general again this is enough of you of
the application site slightly changed
we're looking from the field here so the
application site is here this is the
footpath I've just mentioned and we have
Manston Road and this is Preston Road
I'll take you a lot around the site from
a series of photos we're in Preston Road
this is the War Memorial we have the
church and we have the bow on and this
is further along we can see the barn on
the left-hand side this is the village
hall and nursery this is the existing
access into Monst and green industrial
park and this is looking back you can
see the entrance just behind this tree
here this is the barn this is the old
village hall the application site at
this point doesn't come as far along
Preston Road as this but just to give
some bearings this is the actual
interest in a footpath that we saw on
the previous aerial shops and this is
are now looking at man stone road this
is round in the corner and you're just
looking before the application site
would be coming towards you on the
right-hand side if you're travelling
towards us the opposite side opposite
way of the car and so this is the
application site this is the footpath on
the Left where it comes out that's do
believe there Jubilee cottages looking
in the distance there and this is part
of the application site with six
properties are proposed and this is
moving forward again towards Jubilee
cottages and this is even closer onto
because as you can see the two pairs of
semi-detached and there would be the
access road that serve their main
proportion of the residential units sort
of sitting in this location here and
this is the other side of the man stone
green farm entry
Road where the two bungalows are
proposed just a couple of photographs of
that this is number one the green and
again it's the two bungalows would sit
within this location here and again you
can see some of the trees that are
proposed to be retained on that site and
these some of the existing commercial
buildings within the industrial site
again this is part of the application
site and looking out to the existing
buildings don't use for business uses at
present this is actually standing on the
site that's going to be really used for
a residential development and you can
see in the background here that is their
head jump that own trees the footpath
and this is looking on still on the site
looking out towards Manston Road and
that is number one Jubilee cottages you
can see on the left-hand side and the
access road for the main sort of
residential area of development or would
come in there so you can merely look at
the pond here we've got main residential
area area the shop and cafe proposed the
business units that are talked about and
two last sort of residential dwellings
here the application site is actually
outside of the village envelope and is
in the countryside has has been
mentioned there is an extant consent it
is slightly different because it
proposes 19 units residential units for
live work units but also the cafe and
shop on site and that is still extant
but nevertheless without the extent
consent it is still considered by member
by officers that the site is enclosed by
landscaping and our four physical
features and it would be seen as a
logical expansion of the village and it
would also contribute to their housing
numbers for the district as well as
providing employment
opportunities and a community facility
in the shop cafe so I like to just have
a look at some of the elements of the
development in more detail I'm going to
go first to the residential main element
here and as members can see each unit
has parking spaces they have elements of
garden and it appears as a small cold
sack residential development this is the
plan in more detail you'll see some
sections here so I'll take you through
on the next slide section a and B which
is along the new access road and what
you would see if you were looking at the
residential gives me development there
so this is elevation a and that
properties are quite traditional in
design they are two-story all two-story
mainly free and four bedrooms materials
are quite traditional as well they take
references from materials that are used
in the village already so there's brick
there's tile hanging there's clay towels
to the roof
if we look I'll or have a look at
section C and D now which is are the
properties that frontman Stone Road and
also the properties at the very end of
the cul-de-sac here again they are
traditional in design they use a mix of
materials but again they take up on the
materials that are used throughout the
village so this would be the top section
here see see it are the properties that
would frontman stand Road and they take
some reference points of being
semi-detached and following a sort of
traditional pattern from the Jubilee
cottages wouldn't sit approximately
there but we're seeing the side
elevation of plot 26 which sits further
within the site properties on in the end
of the cold sack of silly
but they again they're traditional and
two-story in nature with similar
materials we're going to let go now and
look at the shop cafe development this
is the main sort of entrance of the shop
and cafe it's quite traditional again in
nature we had the South elevation and
the North elevation and then the West
elevation of that and the floor plan of
it so it is mainly a single storey
building there is a sort of terraced
area around the building and there is a
Mesozoic mezzanine area and some storage
etc that would be on the upper floor I'm
going to take you now to have a look at
the business area that's being proposed
we're going to look first at this these
units here which are units one to eight
so this is the South elevation this is
what you see as you arrived into the
industrial complex so this would be
essentially be the front elevation this
would be the rear elevation and leave
the to flank elevations I'm looking
again at the floor plans
it's the largely a single storey
building in terms of uses but there will
be two units with mezzanine floor space
I will look then at this building here
which is enough of a b-1 office small
start up building and also the lock up
units which it could be used in
association with the proposed business
units so again this would be the front
elevation of these units so you have
single storey and it's here and slightly
lower units to either side and again
this is the rear elevation we're looking
and in the flank elevations so in terms
of floor space we have the single storey
bit a slightly higher bits here and the
main two-story bulk of building and this
is the first floor so you can see the
bits that are single-story and the main
bulk that is two storey
which is in the middle of the building
and these are the proposed lockup units
they are proposed to be only used in the
association with the main business units
and they would not have traffic
generation or comings and goings in
their own right and again that's the F
renovations of those I'll now pay to
look at the bungalows that proposed and
to get some bearings on this one we have
Manston green farm the access of Monson
Road which serves that and the reference
has been made if in the report to a TPO
and that's TPO tree preservation order
ten of 2001 which related to the grounds
of man stone green farm and also the
land adjacent for Jubilee cottages which
essentially is this site originally the
scheme that came in bungalow two was in
a slightly different position and a
number of trees were to be lost
including this tree which we saw a
photograph of which is a tulip tree and
some other trees here which these were
all subject to the tree preservation
order appeared to be having done some
research in it it is clear that this
unit tree is covered by the TPO it's the
right species and of about the right
size to be there in 2001 it is less
clear whether these trees here are of
the correct species or of a size and to
has been there to be covered by the
original TPO
but the bungalow has been moved to allow
for the retention of the tulip tree
which is covered by the TPO these two
trees would be lost but there is
additional planting proposed here so it
is considered to be on balance a
sensible solution I'll just have a look
at the floor plans and elevations for
those bungalows this is bungalow number
one so this is the closest to number
four jubilee cottages as you can see
it's very simplistic it is a two-bedroom
bungalow
sorry three-bedroom bungalow and that's
elevations
and they would actually front a wave
these two bungalows from Manston Road
and be served off an access road off of
Manston green the access road to Madison
Green farm but this is bungalow 2 and
again a similar design as I said it has
been a subject of detailed negotiations
with members sorry officers and a
console tease it is a low-density
development being of 23 dwellings per
hectare which we do consider to be
acceptable given the edge of village
location for the site there have been a
number of concerns raised in by local
residents and indeed in the statements
that have just been read out in relation
to highway letters that are proposed
with the developments I will just show
you those and they are condition to come
forward in the conditions that are on
the application the first one is looking
at Manston Road there would be a
pavement proposed the footpath along the
front of the new dwellings this is the
new access road that's come in and then
a footpath that front would front the
new bungalows proposed and joined the
footpath where it just turns a corner
and goes off to towards the green and
into Preston Road I mean it does also
include the slight movement of the
traffic islands that we saw this is this
side the access road to the industrial
park as it currently stands sits closer
to the barn is pretty much adjacent
through the barn it's been slightly
moved over with the agreement of
Highways to allow better visibility
splays to be achieved and there will be
a small crossing proposed again to serve
to gain access to the footpath that is
on this side of president road there
will be yellow lines proposed fent
parking and to ensure this has been
a long Manston road in front of these
dwellings and also along here in Preston
Road and as I said that is to ensure
that visibility adequate visibility and
can be achieved for both the entrances
and to avoid on street parking that's
might know her on the road or cause
highway issues KCC are happy with the
visibility's displays and excuse me
access arrangements as now proposed and
the number of parking spaces that are
proposed within the development both in
the residential and the shop and cafe
and the business units they do not
consider the traffic generation from the
proposed development would be
unacceptable having it significantly
adverse effect on the highway safety in
this location so is so just going back
to sum up it is in the countryside the
application site but it is as your
village it is low density in terms of
residential numbers it would provide a
shop and cafe an important community
facility and also the industrial units
here there are a number of conditions
I'm sure member of the members will have
seen attached to the report which deal
with issues such as drainage archaeology
contamination construction management
plans and all sorts of highway issues
and things you'd expect to come forward
on an application of this scale there is
a need for a section 106 as would be
expected and that would secure various
contributions for example a contribution
to CCG the normal Sam contribution for
the special protection area as well as a
number of others which are all set out
in the report and as what it will also
secure the affordable housing and the
provision and initial fit out of the
shop cafe units so on that basis offices
are recommending that members defer and
delegate the application to OFF for
approval to officers to
your detail of that section 106 Thank
You chair Thank You Annabelle and yes I
move the officers recommendation as
you've just mentioned could I have a
second to please
Oh second that chair Thank You
councillor Coleman cook members do you
wish to debate well I can't see you come
up counselor garner I'm sorry coming to
say no but now you verb me so yes don't
carry on okay thank you
there's a cut there's a couple of points
I'd like to raise having read through
the report on I do have concerns about
or in the first one around the trees
being lost that are covered by the TP oh
I see there seems to have been a number
of different surveys and it almost looks
as if there's different surveys been
carried on carried out to sort of muddy
the waters enough to try and convince
people that trees that were and are
covered by TVO's aren't anymore I'm not
sure if they're the ones that were
mentioned at the beginning in the
statement of his read the trees at the
end of their lifespan and I'm not quite
sure what a tree at the end their
lifespan is because all all trees are
alive until they fall over and they're
all valuable the older they get so I'm
not sure about that you're not very
happy about the loss of trees covered by
OTP oh the other area that I've read in
the report that wasn't really gone into
it in detail was around this being a
hotspot for contamination and there was
quite a lot it was stated as a sensitive
setting for groundwater resources
because this is this is an area of
groundwater resources and I think I read
it it was seen as a high-risk
development and I see there are a number
of yeah there are a number of statements
of grounds that have to be covered
but I'm still very concerned about that
for what what at the end of the day is
as if noted in the report a windfall
housing site it isn't the site as are
far as I can see and as he stated as
that's identified in the local in the
draft local plan for housing in fact
that I think in the report states that
in terms of housing needs they've got
they that there's not supported by the
inspectors report for there being extra
housing there is a five year supply and
this is a windfall site and I think the
great there's quite a great wait but on
this that it supplies a shop stroke cafe
and if it wasn't supplying the shot
stroke cafe this wouldn't necessarily be
a site that would be approved so for now
there's a couple of things that I wanted
to raise from an interested hear what
other people say and the other one there
was one other side just note in around
the archaeology and there has been a
number this area has been previously
evaluated and remains have been found on
the site so I'm obviously keen keen for
that to be to make sure that we don't
lose what our killer are here logical
development and then there needs to be
before any development is progressed on
this site that's my comments for now I
like to look forward to listening to
what everybody else has got to say on
this Thank You counsel counsel right
Thank You mr. chairman I'm a little bit
confused here I'm just trying to wonder
the two bungalows as I remember they
were turned down had a planning
application turned down because they
were in the in the green bell in the
countryside and suddenly they've got
another application in that's being
recommended the other thing is I would
be very interested to hear the response
from the Madison parish council that
that should be in the report that's
right
No I've lost you know I turned off I
haven't actually got it to hand is a
refreshment refreshment refresher I
don't know whether Annabelle can answer
otherwise I'll move on for the time yes
if you would Thank You Annabelle I
couldn't cover the points councillor
right hand councillor go on if that
would be helpful yes in terms of the
bungalows it is correct there was a
previous application where bungalows
were refused on the site and it did lead
and I haven't got the decision to hand
but there was a and it did lead to the
actual tree preservation order being put
on the site but then there was a
subsequent approval for the tube out for
two bungalows on the site which avoided
the preserve trees so that I think the
refusal application was to do more to do
with the impact on landscaping but
subsequently to that refusal there has
been an actual approval for two
bungalows on that site prior to this
application coming forward thank you
in terms of talk if we stay with the
bungalow site which is the area with the
tpo there have been a number of a tree
surveys and things carried out it sensed
it was one tree survey that was
submitted with the application and
further work has been done because he
did come to light looking at a tree
preservation order that not all of the
trees might still be that were included
in the original order asked it on-site
as explained the large share my screen
that would be helpful if members can see
my screen in just a moment
it's these trees here and it's probably
not that easy to see that our subject or
in the sort of approximate positions for
the TPO
this is the tulip tree that is being
retained and that definitely is covered
by the TP o because it's the correct
speed she's Anna correct size to have
been there in 2001 so that's why the
bungalow was shifted and that tree is to
remain these trees here it is slightly
unclear they don't seem to tie up
species wise with the list of trees in
the tree preservation order and they
appear to be of quite a limited size and
compared to what you'd imagine if they
were had been there since 2001 or prior
to 2001 so that is why the compromise
has been accepted also at the basis that
additional planting will be proposed
here that we don't have certainty those
are the trees here that were contained
within the tree preservation order but
we are seeking to retain the chute tree
that we saw the photograph of and that
is a large and healthy tree and is
certainly named on the TPO
so hopefully that covers excuse me that
point in terms of contamination I think
was raised it it is correct that it's a
sensitive site in terms of that and that
is dealt with in the report and there
are a number of conditions I think
they're mainly three four and five and
they're quite detailed that have been
suggested by the Environment Agency to
deal with that matter they are saying
subject to those conditions being
attached to any grant of consent that it
is acceptable and would not have an
adverse impact on in terms of
contamination or on the water supply and
I think the final point if I remember
counts that Donna was related to
archaeology again kcci Lord archaeology
team have reviewed the site and there
was information submitted to support the
application in deal with this matter and
they have also found the scheme to be
acceptable and subject to I can't find
the competition with me but there is a
condition that we
to further work to assess the impact and
the archeology prior to any works
commencing on site and that's the pre
commencement condition as I say so
the archeology will be reviewed and
assessed prior to any building works
taking place on site thank you for that
um I do have two other speakers but also
councillor garner I believe you wish to
come back yes quickly
so on the on the on those TP o--'s I
know it's one corner of the site but I
think it's an important point to make so
there was it there is an area TPO
they're covering a number of trees since
2001 I think you said one of those trees
has been identified as a tulip tree the
other trees we're not sure if they're
included so it's only there's only two
options here either those trees that are
there are covered by that TPO or they've
been removed so I'm just making that
point that means trees covered by an EPO
if they're not those ones there then
they've been removed and there should or
they could at some time be an
investigation as I know there have been
other trees removed covered by other
area Te'o's in other parts of the
district and and investigations are
ongoing on those I just want us to be
make sure that you know if we're looking
somewhere and we're not sure where the
trees have gone then they've been
removed and they've been removed
illegally that's not or no we need to
make okay thank you very your point now
councillor garner I'm sure that has been
noted okay
captain Taylor Thank You chair
Uncas us and Annabelle she can show the
photograph of Menston Road with the
Julie cottages with the road though
she's able to find that on my screen and
then I'll share the road with the
Jubilee cottages I'm happy with the
actual application will be both through
but I just wanted a highways issue too
just confirm really that's fine
Oh seaworthy I know there it goes into a
30 mile per hour limit so obviously
leading up up to live is I believe is 40
miles an hour isn't it you're coming
from that bends oh so you've got the
access road coming out from there what
question is what I mean I don't know if
it's written in the report actually I
read a lot of it but you can't cover all
of it but was it gonna be made 30 mile
per hour further back by the bend then
you know if I understand the meaning I
do understand no it is not proposed to
shift a speed limit and KCC have agreed
that that's the position there was some
debate during the application about
where the 30 mile an hour speed limit
should kick in so to speak but it is not
proposed to move it from position at the
current time and KCC highways have
confirmed they're happy with that thanks
Phyllis Thank You counselor counselor
Hart
hello yeah yeah I mean it sir you clean
up today yeah I'm concerned slightly
about this this is in my ward and it's
there's a couple of issues I haven't
obviously the parish council picked up
one or two as well basically this shop
will they it might end up that the shop
just turned into another house because
they just said there's not enough people
to support the shop which is generally
the way it happens also we're building
into green belt land and should we
really be doing that
it's outside the Manston confines of the
village so we're basically just building
on greenfield sites there's enough
brownfield sites around and that is a
very fast road I have an access road
into it and how many cars are going to
come in and out of that they've done a
lie couldn't see that in the report as
in movements of traffic because that is
a very quick road round there and people
do lickety-split wrap it and it's just
to make sure that everybody is aware
that you know are we building on green
green sites just because this
applications been put in you with me I
think that can Annabelle can you answer
that sorry I can try sure
in terms of its country side rather than
green land or Greenbelt so I'd like to
clarify that position and park most of
the site certainly where the residential
the main bulk of the residential is
proposed and other areas have already
been the subject of the previous
application and that's why it's actually
in it forms part of the five-year
housing land supplied identified within
the emerging draft local plan so it is
not a new site on top of that the count
the current 19 I think it sorry 19th
wedding 's plus the fall live work units
so 23 dwellings are already accounted
for within the five-year housing land
supply just to pick up on that point and
in terms of speed limits and access
roads obviously it was has been a
subject the whole application of lots of
tooing and froing between the KCC as a
highway there's the highway authority
and the applicants for the scheme and it
has been agreed that the highway works
that are now being proposed are
acceptable and levels of traffic
competition using the access wouldn't be
significantly harmful or dangerous to
the to the site to the point of the site
not being acceptable to come forward
I think hopefully that's covered all the
points raised by Councillor hot Thank
You Annabelle okay I can't see any other
speakers here on my list so once again
I'm going to put this to the vote and I
think we're getting used to this it's
four against or abstain when I call your
name out please
so certainly counselor comment cook for
councillor Albin four counts of a foot
for councillor curry for councilors esky
abstain councillor Duckworth for
counselor garner against counselor Hart
against counselor keen and abstain
councillor Taylor for Council right
against and myself for I'm sure I've
ticked off but I'm sure Emily will do
better than I can
my belief that has carried before Thank
You Emily yes that motion has been
carried Thank You members moving on to
the last item on the agenda which is who
farm one four seven
Moncton Road Minster application is
thought referral and going over to David
do a while this afternoon David
surrealist from its from a ravemon t'
who's raising points of concern thank
you by mr. Adrian Raymond Jeff Thanet
Council and Planning applicants in
regards to the above meeting and
continued movement towards planning
consent
I would to take this opportunity to
remind one and all a pending business
oblique livelihood disruption that will
inevitably result from granting planning
for 23 dwelling on who farm with the
first action of planning to take level
existing business what are the
ramifications to the granting planning
consent at who farm there are several
elements that will massively impact on
our business
number one unit seven who farm was
specifically chosen to represent the
craft stroke design nature of raymond
weil limited and is one of the many
reasons we have been at who farm for
over 15 years who farm projects a very
specific imagery for our online
visibility across many platforms raiment
wire limited relies heavily on this
visual medium to represent who we are at
present and in the future
number two our predicted financial
disruption is without doubt significant
the costs related to raymond wise
relocation and the subsequent business
earnings disruption is predictable
number three tenants rights tenant act
1954 in summary one we require
assistance and an adequate time period
to relocate to a like a like place the
business to keep disruption to an
absolute minimum and retain continuity
to good working practice two we require
financial compensation against the costs
and disruption two raymond weil limited
during this period and that's the end of
that report sorry state thank you thank
you David
right then move to the planning officer
which is who is the me check Thank You
Ian yes your report please
just present my my screen the
application is for the erection of 23
dwellings following the demolition of
the existing buildings on the process as
who farm the main issues for members to
consider for this application is the
principal development the character and
appearance of the area impact on
neighbors and also impact on highway
safety and this is brought before
members as its outside of the identified
urban confines so the site is outlined
in red on your screen and you can see
that there are a number of buildings in
situ on the site at the moment
combination of light industrial storage
buildings and also farm buildings so the
site is previously developed land but it
is outside of the urban confines so this
is an aerial image of the site this is
the site in relation to the outskirts of
Minster so some members will be familiar
with some other sites that we've looked
at in the past that are on the edge of
the urban confines of Minster so looking
at the site itself from the ground so
this is on Moncton Road to the east of
the site looking back towards the site
so here are a number of dwellings that's
in front of the site in question moving
a little bit closer in then you can see
the existing vehicle access to the site
that's proposed to be remodeled and used
to access the proposed development then
that's the other view of that same
access then this is looking up the
access so you see there's a change in
levels as you go into the site and you
can see one of the the buildings that's
present on site at the moment and then
turning to the
left you can see a collection of
single-story but with with high pitched
roof buildings present for those uses as
identified then going back along
mountain roads traveling along the to
the to the west these the properties
that front montón Road so two story
traditionally designed residential
dwellings and then this is a view
looking back towards the site and back
towards those properties and then going
back towards the west you've got on the
very right extent of this image you have
a listed wall that you can just see the
edge of and there's an existing vehicle
er access that we're just going to go up
now so turning right off Mountain Road
here will take you up to an area that's
behind the dwellings that we just saw
fronting Mountain Road and you can see
the industrial buildings in the
background there that are proposed for
for demolition turning left up that
access row dude you can see that there
are a number of residential properties
in the corner of the site this is on the
left-hand side of the image of
continuation of the listed wall and on
the very right extent of the image you
can see an existing building that was
under the prior approval process to a
couple of dwellings and then what I'm
just going to show you is a view from
the center of this parking area so where
the cursor is looking towards the site
first of all so just to show looking in
that parking area again you can see this
is a building that's that's been
converted so that's not proposed as part
of this development to be demolished but
the buildings on the right are then you
have the other buildings use high
pitched roofs
you've got so sort of a two-story in
height but with a pitched roof so it's
single-story but they're quite high and
then this is turning back towards the
rear of the nearest property on montón
Road to what ones that we were looking
at earlier to see this this property has
an open rear garden with parking air but
the others have have private amenity
space at the rear so as mentioned the
proposal is to demolish properties on
site and erect 23 Wellings so the
principle issues here are the fact the
site is outside the urban confines but
the site is previously developed land so
there is a draft local plan policy that
specifically looks at this for
development the countryside which allows
compatible development on developed
sites in the countryside as long as all
other material plan considerations are
satisfactory dealt with so therefore the
impact on the countryside and longer
views in the landscape character error
is the key so the key issues in terms of
the impact on the character and
appearance of the area and the
countryside so given the presence of
buildings on the site it is considered
there is potential for development here
and so our officers have looked at the
extent of the development and whether or
not it's it caused a significant impact
on the countryside when there is the
presence of of buildings on site at the
moment and it's not an allocated
employment site and the speech that we
heard related primarily to issues
between a landlord and a tenant and they
are not planning considerations as they
are dealt with through separate civil
legislation so in terms of relocation of
existing businesses that is not a
principal planning issue as the sky is
not allocated for employment use so in
terms of the development itself it's
primarily two-story with some one and a
half story development as you can see at
the bottom of the image it uses the
existing access to come in there's no
connection between other access on the
left-hand side here into the site so it
would utilize the existing road but
obviously make it good as you saw it was
a it was a it was a track more than
anything and obviously that's to be made
good with with landscaping the density
of the proposal is is about 29 drawings
per hectare
so it's it's the sort of edge of the
urban confines scale of development the
density is in terms of its acceptability
is primarily dictated by the presence of
the buildings on site and again whether
or not the amount of developments
proposed would appear cramped in its
countryside context it's not considered
that the development would result in in
harm on those grounds and indeed there
were previously proposed to be two
dwellings in this open space on the
right hand side of the image which were
removed as part of the negotiation about
the planning application to ensure there
was an undue impact because that area is
currently consists of open space that
has amenity in in the area so the
proposal is for 12 2 bit properties and
11 3 their properties which we consider
is an acceptable mix I'm just going to
very quickly go through the elevations
of the proposal so first of all looking
at the elevations that front Mont and
Road and then the front elevations of
the properties that back on to those
properties so that there are front
elevations on the internal Road in the
site so on the top of the image that you
can see is the proposed design of the
properties on Moncton Road and the
bottom image shows the design of the
dwellings that front that internal Road
note the property on the right-hand side
of the image on the bottom I'll show
more detail of that when talking out
impact on living conditions and then
moving to the back of the site looking
at the other front elevations of the
properties that are to the north of the
site that the front onto the internal
access road and also then looking at the
elevations the front on to the
countryside the top image are those that
front the internal road the red line
that you can see shows the scale of the
developments at the moment so you'll
note that the rig the eaves height of
the proposed development does not exceed
the height of the buildings at the
moment but the ridge fight does in
this instance we've considered that
because the designer is pitching away
from the boundary with the countryside
when looking at the image at the bottom
here that we don't consider there is a
significant truce and impact on the
landscape character area when seen from
widen it the materials that have
proposed as part of this development are
matched those in the in the the locality
so it's brickwork it's it's tile hung it
has some cladding as well as clay tiles
and generally we consider the scale of
the development is appropriate and you
can see this particularly when looking
at the next set of elevations which
front the access road into the site on
the left-hand side as well as then
seeing the front elevations of the
properties that are perpendicular to
road and the internal access road so you
can see the top image is the section
through the site so showing what you get
from the access roads you can see that
there is a level change but the
dwellings on the at the top of the site
as you'd call it are two storey with two
storey designed on the the properties
that front that internal road so just to
give a bit more detail the ones that
front Mountain Road just to show you so
this is the the actual design of those
properties again sort of showing they're
proposing to have brickwork similar to
the existing properties that are on
Mountain Road and it's considered that
the design and scale of this are
appropriate to avoid any any impact on
the couch and appearance of the area
with the rear elevation has been clad
but that's not highly visible from oh
it's not visible from the front and we
don't consider it to be inappropriate in
this area just too and then these are
the side elevations show you this
dwelling in particular because you
members can see properties are a lot
that front Monson Road that we saw the
rear of and obviously the one of the key
issues to ensure is that there's no
impact on the living conditions of
neighboring properties and the report
deals with this and looks specifically
at what was unit number 21
which is the one to the north of at
number 139 Moncton Road and so this
property has been designed as a bungalow
and it is proposed by officers to
include a removal of limited development
rights on this particular property to
avoid an impact on the relationship with
the neighboring property to the south in
terms of highway issues the site
proposes 38 spaces for 23 dwellings with
one allocated space per dwelling that
which leaves 15 unallocated spaces
highways consider that to be sufficient
for the development and the scale of the
development and unit sizes that have
been proposed this plan does to show so
cycling and bin storage you know for
each property but as each property has
its own amenity space it's not consider
that this would result in a particular
issue there are requirements that are
placed upon this application relating
specifically to an area of footway if
you look at this image with the X and
the y and to ensure that this property's
development would accord with
sustainability principles it's required
as part of this development of footways
to be provided a long mountain road to
connect this development with the
existing footway that runs into Minster
that you might be able to just see in
this area here and this is put on as a
as a Grampian condition so it's a no
development shall take place until that
has been secured and provided so that is
an important point for members um just
to touch on one other matter that is
covering the report but I mentioned that
the listed wall of France mountain road
is obviously present and an in proximity
with this scheme the who farm house
itself is listed so here is our site
here and the who farm house is listed
you wouldn't be able to see it from the
photos because it's significantly
screened from by landscaping
and this was looked at during the course
the application with the previous
conservation officer raising some
concerns with the initial submission
about its potential impact these
concerns have have been resolved then
it's not considered that the development
as proposed would be any worse in terms
of heights and relationship than the
existing buildings in terms of how they
relate to the listed building and the
wall so it's not considered to result in
in harm on those grounds in terms of
other elements in the scheme we have a
heads of terms outlined in the report
this includes 30 percent affordable
housing on-site contributions towards
education contributions was Minster
library secured contributions towards a
waste facilities as well as the surgery
at Minster the SAMS contribution to the
special protection area and a
contribution towards additional
equipment at the nearest play area in
Minster and therefore overall whilst the
dome is outside the urban confines the
redevelopment does provide some
additional housing units on a previously
developed site with limited harm to the
landscape character area and the
countryside with benefits from the
footpath contributions and also the
general benefit of the provision of
housing without causing harm to
neighboring properties and therefore the
recommendation is to defer and delegate
the application for approval subject to
the receipt of the section 106 and the
the safeguarding conditions
thank you chap thank you very much again
so I move that the officers
recommendation is adopted could I have a
seconder please second Rancher make
against a common cook
are there any speakers please yeah I'd
like to just first couple of things
please sure yep Ariane Casa Donna just
one one point of clarification so I
think there was a little relate to the
last application I was a bit confused
about the housing supply
now looking at this with the report for
this one this speights in the rapport
that this is it's acknowledged that this
is a full application of twenty-three
vigil units on previous divinity site
which would be considered to make a
modest contribution towards the house
insight as a windfall housing site so
this isn't this is an area that's
included in the local plan so these are
extra houses on top of the housing that
is identified in the draft local plan
that's true in in thank check yes so
this is this isn't allocated as a site
and as it's outside the old confines
that's why it's being reported to
members as a departure and so we we are
now in a position where we are able to
show that there is a demonstrable five
year supply when taking the draft local
plan but what the new local plan does
require is when development is outside
the urban confines it doesn't
automatically mean that it would be
refused and it has to be considered on
its merits and in terms of countryside
sites specifically there is a specific
policy which is SP 24 which looks at
where there is a developed site with
buildings on in the countryside that it
should be considered on its merits as to
whether or not it could come forward and
so that's why it's been put forward that
this would be a windfall site of which
the local plan does make provision for
windfall sites that aren't allocated
sites to come forward to help the
housing supply in the district okay
understood and there's one thing I noted
in the report which I don't think you
mentioned was this is this is an area of
a swift listing site you wish to come
back a million what provision to being
my if any to to to support the Swift
nesting somewhere else so in terms of
the specific requirements of
the the comments of the KCC biodiversity
officers so we've got recommendations
that were provided in a preliminary
ecological assessment that was that was
carried out and submitted including the
provision of a swallow nesting site so
that is a requirement of the condition
and that's prior to the completion the
development and KCC ecology are happy
with the imposition of the conditions to
deal with that so we will expect details
of that to be submitted there are also
provisions made within condition 19
specifically about lighting design to be
provided and that is again a different
other-- recommendation that's been the
ecological appraisal that was submitted
thank you but thank you
yes Aloha yeah Thank You chair as you
know we're again this is in my in my
ward mat the parish council had quite a
few concerns on this one of the main
ones is that this is a rural development
which means that you have to drive to
this development and yet there's not two
parking spaces for each house and then
one of their main concerns is they're
going to end up on the road we've gained
reasonably tight Road it's gonna be
impede the view of the people leaving
that site to have safe access or
entrance into that site what are your
views on this carry on
future so in terms of of that that is
something that again was looked down a
lot DITA and specifically it resulted in
again quite a bit of back and forth with
holidays and specifically delays in
terms of sorting out the requirements of
needing the footpath to Minster and
obviously you have quite a range of
facilities at Minster and therefore
that's one of the reasons why it's
absolutely key that the footpath is
provided prior to the development
actually starting and it's a case that
if that footpath can't be provided for a
reason the
wouldn't come forward so that's one
element things to try and encourage non
Karl travel where possible in terms of
trips into the village or indeed that
potentially not every occupier of the
site might need two cars but
specifically the in terms of the parking
that has been considered you know by
highways it's considered this sufficient
provision with you know the unallocated
spaces that are provided and indeed if
there was in the in the future specific
problems that would be as a result of
this development in terms of the new
parking on the road with no restrictions
which would cause issues with visibility
then in in the skin in the future that
is something that of CKC see highways
can look at separately through traffic
regulation orders in the event that that
were to occur but KCC highways are happy
with the amount of parking on site to
avoid parking on street and in terms of
making sure that there is the ability
for people to travel to Minster and the
services that are there and without
having to rely on their car that that's
one of the reasons why the footpath is
also required Thank You chair Thank You
Ian I come back from that chair yes
Kephart thank you very much and also in
that they did pass comment about the
over fifty-five and there's no real sort
of provision for them how many people
over 55 wanna buy a three or four
bedroom houses on two levels what are
your comments on that as well please
carry on
thank chair um so this was originally
proposed as a restricted over fifty five
s scheme that has now been removed so
the provisions that would potentially
come from that which wouldn't
necessarily be included contributions to
education or affordable housing and also
you know would have had to be in
relation to a specific need those have
been removed so it is a standard housing
development which is providing all of
the required obligations that you would
have on
development of 23 houses thank you so
effectively you're gonna have younger
people with two cars using that place
with not enough places to park which is
engaged what you're trying to say you
get what I mean
I'm sorry checking yes Kerry are you
saying I'm well I wouldn't necessarily
automatically say that that means that
people would definitely have two cars I
think that the point here is that that
the assessments been done about the
level of parking and it's consider it
wouldn't it wouldn't result obviously in
terms of the numbers in a significant
demand for parking on the street it may
be that the demographics of a society
does dictate you know potential parking
requirements but obviously you have got
you know a mix here that includes your
12:00 to bed units so they are smaller
units within the eleven three bed so we
consider the level of parking is is
adequate Thank You councillor garner you
wish to come back yeah just just for
just one point I know every port was
well I remember making know about that
this development is it it's located upon
principal Accra fire it's a bit unique
as well cause it's overlain by a
secondary aquifer and I'm concerned that
again like the previous application
there are this is a risk of residual
contaminate contamination of that aqua
fire we seem to be on are we taking one
application at a time but you know we
could we see me add into the risk to the
the Aqua firing in that area there for
for housing which would add which would
be bonus housing on top of that housing
that we've identified already in the
local plan that's my concern
Thank You counsel Ghana and you wish to
come back um thank you thank you chair
just to come back on that point so there
are there are a number of conditions
which relate to drainage specifically to
ensure that for exam
Paul that we're not allowing for piling
to occur in using penetrative methods
for foundations without express
agreement from us to ensure the
methodology is suitable to avoid
unnecessary contamination it is pretty
whilst whilst unique in the sense of
both principle and secondary aquifer a
large amount of the district is within a
ground water source protection zone or
indeed located on the principal aquifer
so it is something that both are
contaminated land team look at when
asking for the conditions but also the
Environment Agency feed into in terms of
correspondents about it in this instance
we think the conditions are sufficient
to mitigate that risk to avoid there
being a cumulative effect on the aquifer
thank you Jeff thank you and I can't see
anybody else who does wish to speak
please correct me if I'm wrong
Thank You members once again then I will
put this to vote for my shout your name
out for against or abstain I would be
grateful
so councillor coma cook sorry oh just a
moment can I hold you there a moment Oh
Polly councillor recess key did you want
to say something on this I think there's
been a little bit of a chance he was
able to hear the report so I just wanted
to check that he was in a position that
he could still vote thank you Emily
yesterday I saw that come up thank you
for that so if councillor was s queues
with us still am I going to through the
votes yes he has yeah so okay we started
going causa Coleman cook
for hello counselor
oh okay out there don't you okay now
Robin yeah for thank you counts of a
third for cancer curry for there is no
key I'll have to abstain chair as I
missed most of that with my computer
freezing and doing nothing for me I
appreciate that
counselor SSC I think you just use a
hammer next time alright I think so
counselor Duckworth Duckworth do we
still have
I think she's left the meeting chair
sorry
right counsel Ghana against counselor
heart wait counselor keen pool counselor
tailor for counsel right lift has she
gone yeah okay myself I'm for I think
that has gone through I'm sure Emily
will fresh up honest scroll that motion
is carried those gentlemen members
officers that comes to the end of this
meeting at its state earlier on on my
notes here it says good night like are
only that and we've got another one in a
minute so members again thank you very
much
that's see I think it's gone alright
thank you for your time officers as well
David who's doing his reading with the
statements thank you I believe you will
be new informant in very shortly it was
touched on before not
to meeting per month for a couple of
months that you live in what you from
them to be looking at to peak start
fully appreciate that some members it
can be difficult work but hopefully we
can overcome that but yet once again
many thank you and good afternoon
have a good evening